una guerra total una guerra que afecta a
distintas partes del país en la que está
viviendo en Ucrania dónde se ha
estrellado un misil misil interceptado
por las fuerzas ucranianas que ha caído
sobre un gasoducto que ahora amenaza con
dejar a miles de familia sin calefacción
en pleno invierno con bajas temperaturas
esta guerra sin embargo también se está
convirtiendo en la guerra de información
según Moscú se habrán producido unas 500
bajas entre sus tropas mientras que
Ucrania habla de 5000 soldados rusos
fallecido desde el comienzo del
conflicto hace una semana lo que sí
sabemos es que 800.000 ucranianos y unos
50.000 extranjeros han abandonados o sea
el país en el intento desesperado de
huir de las autoridades que continúa
producirse en distintos puntos del país
una situación Por tanto muy complicada
en este en Ucrania en un momento en el
que continúa la negociaciones de pasa
una negociaciones de paz que sin embargo
todavía no dejan prever Cuáles pueden
ser las soluciones para este conflicto
ni cuando esta solución se hará un
públicas y llegarán a los resultados
definitivo